so but it's a it's a whole breathing
thing my ba i the biggest fear is
drowning i've not been able to breathe
like i can't yeah you know over my or if
somebody's hand is over my mouth i i
can't like i can't i can you know what
scene i can't watch is in kill bill
where she's buried alive i don't like
that that's what i'm saying like just
that would be the most nightmarish
death
you could ever do that just happened by
the way okay not not being better that
but i just saw on cnn today yeah i think
it was in china actually that look at me
i don't know why i did that i don't know
why i did that number one i'm not
chinese number two i didn't do it
i didn't do it no you didn't stop
looking at me you're korean yeah
but it just happened that with coven
they put somebody in a body bag
oh that was awesome
alive they were just sick they were just
sick they were loading them on the
gurney and like i don't know
like it was
oh my god i don't know if that's what
happened yeah yeah but somehow he
started breathing or whatever and like
they opened they unzipped the bag don't
take me word for word on this i just saw
the phone on the caption but like
they unzipped it unlocked it and he was
still alive what would you say
hello hello hello is that the hello
hello
yeah hi hello
[Laughter]
you're looking forward to
i think
i think
the first thing a normal human being
would say
is what the [ __ ] yeah
what the f what the [ __ ] no cause i
think if he was truly as sick as he was
he would have been not in a truly lucid
state okay but hello is not i don't
think
did he live
he's alive oh good thank god yeah
now now now the new question is there's
probably a couple of dudes
yeah i mean because if there's one they
caught oh they killed there's gotta be a
two or three or maybe a hundred didn't
make it yeah they didn't make it yeah
yeah
yeah i mean imagine that like being like
about to be embalmed
oh
what do you mean like you're you know
when they embalmed they have to drain
the blood from your veins and stuff to
like preserve you think that's ever
happened where they put the tubes in
look it up guild and then you look over
and go anyway
there is a
yeah
is that
that
yeah that's what i saw in shanghai oh my
god he woke up
oh
my god that's that that is that's that's
what i'm talking about
but what's worse than that though is
waking up and you're in a casket six
feet underground
because you can say hello a million
times hello yeah yeah no one's here i
mean so in that circumstance what is the
first thing you do
i you know this is making me
i know right you're right but it is
crazy
like i'd rather but it's more freeing to
talk about it because i do lay there at
night and sit and think about these
[ __ ] up like these crates like if i
were stuck in a casket yeah below the
sea level and somebody left me there
yeah what the [ __ ] would i do like i do
think about it wait isn't there don't
they tell you what to do i think there
are strategies i know i already know it
this is all i kill bill you you punch
yeah what's this what the [ __ ] is this
this girl was woke up in a funeral home
and put it on her body i thought she was
dead wow
she looks dead there
oh that's a pain
[Laughter]
hello i don't know why we're talking
about this this is really getting dark
but let's since we're going down this
but there's a lot of movies that have
this particular scenario yeah that is
because it's it's i can't i can't even
imagine how many people like this that's
their worst fear
well we were watching the northmen last
night and there was one scene where i
looked at kaleilago uh this is traumatic
which is you know they're raiding a
village yes they take the kids and women
they put them in a house like a
and they just light it on fire a hut
yeah and they just light it on fire i
mean that's just like
and they used to do [ __ ] like that back
in the day
oh my and there was no emdr there's no
they didn't have better help
they didn't have better help right and
so you couldn't zoom a therapist
like what did they do back then for
trauma
[Music]
online therapy
you guys um
i love better help more than anything
else in the